おっ
始め
社長です
ご覧の通りサクサクと部屋の片づけが進んでおります
ちょっと見てみますか結構きれいになりましたよ汚いんですけどここらへんに今荷物が
飾ったしから片っ端からで片っ端に片っ端から
片っ端結果も四つよげですね地ツアー
明日ん
マッサージねぇ動画だすときは強化もどっちでもいいや
松レイズちょっと二物をひとまずおうちにタイマーに帰ります
バイクバイク持ってるんですけどやっぱ長い間ら日本に帰らなかったらバイクダメに
なると思ったんだよ
灰きれい富山に帰りますすぐに持つとかも全部持っていきたいんですけど
it でこんなんですよ絶対もっと上尾んじゃないですか普通にどっちが by か
わからんみたいなことになるんねちょっと手伝ってもらって
荷物置きに行こうと思います今作ったりカメラでも
まあなんかバイクの像が取れると思ったんですけど
やっぱり画質じゃないんだよバディバディ
カメラバディが大事ということでさあケチャッたんですけど
とって
まあ変えましたよ
新しいビデオカメラですまあこれはですねー
あの
ちょっとまあまあ家あげますよ見てもらえばわかると思うんですけど
hx 生
a チーク w へ30トイカメラです
ええっ
これ本当にヤバいんですよ防水ずうメートルまで海の底に落としてもいいですえっと何
氷に強い
スローモーション防塵耐衝撃
1.2センチから落としても終わりません
を色々入ってますねん
ほいきました megaman zero ちょっと形が変わっています
あとバスペリーとずうずう電気が入っています
なんで撮ってみるか
哈哈哈撮るとこうきての好きーの
自撮りするときは
コーシーのですよ今とっています
ズーム
全然きれいさんめっちゃ綺麗だよ
全然綺麗
今これで今こっちで撮ったのはこっちです
何て言えばいいんだっ
ここらへんに載せていますここらへんかこれ
ここらへんにまあ多分画像が載っています
全然きれい全然いけるわというわけで次は動画はバイクで富山県の旅です
さあまず味でしてかな
うん
wh